how's it going citizens of the reject Nation we
are back once again to take on ten Masters that's
right it's time for Ip Man Two I am very excited
and thank you guys for just being so gracious and
for responding so well to the first Ip Man I
cannot wait to continue the series and with
me in the hot seat is Roxy stryer how you doing
Roxy yeah I'm so glad that they liked the first
one because I was really nervous we were never
gonna be able to watch the second one and I've
been like anxiously waiting for this oh sure well
and with Donnie and tearing it up in John Wick
chapter four now is the perfect time so guys why
don't you go ahead and leave a like on this video
go ahead and subscribe to the channel subscribe
to roxystryer as well as the World Girls how the
world girls doing they're whirling baby oh yeah
whirling and twirling gonna repeat the joke from
the first intro it got better the second time so
much better he's swirling the third time swirling
Merlin and uh hurling you're Sterling like silver
but we're gold but you're gold there you go that's
what I've been told and hey if you want to get the
full on I appreciate it I feel so supportive if
you want the full on experience with us everything
that doesn't make these reaction highlights come
on over to our patreon page patreon.com the real
rejects where you can sync up with your own copy
of Ip Man 2 and enjoy the complete experience
alongside us and uh Hey without further Ado you
ready to throw down on some Kung Fu action is
Rock C ready to rock yeah are you ready to see
you ready to Wing Chun yeah you know it
let's jump into this dude I feel like
there's a pun that I am missing
but we'll find it after that okay
how many years after did this come out a few two
two 2010 we're in okay the year is 2010 year is
2010. Roxy's in high school and she's ready
for it man too I'm in college at this point
baby ready for it man too but apparently
not because here we are in 2023 yet again
starting with that dull color
yeah last time on Ip Man
oh buddy whoa
like Sin City all of a sudden
oh I'm excited I've seen a couple of his movies
it looks sketched totally in the background
that's wild yeah it's a cool combination yeah
score is beautiful too it's so swelling and Epic
it's interesting too it just an action
director there's so much action it's
a whole job sure absolutely it's like
choreographer almost I guess thank you
I'm never too good for your daily practice do you
know what that thing's called
you know I should comment below
I feel like a dojo kind of thing yeah it's
gonna open up his official school
he's ready to really teach can you
turbina somehow those clothes are going
to become Kung Fu the sheets I like that
she said clothes it's like 15 sheets
you know it's not about fabrics and
garments it's about martial arts okay
totally it's not laundry man [__]
oh no
you see the inner conflict it's so not like him to
knock at the door and confront the problems head
on yeah and especially after where they came from
the first movie and how to be in this position
to go from like tyrannical oppression to
now just trying to scrape by prior to that
being just so rich yeah ever poised though foreign
I mean hello
clearly a student of principle
oh a jean jacket feels restrictive for that I know
it's a heavy cloth although
it might make good protection
showing like new school
versus old school right yeah
oh God that's just like multiple punches or so
visceral yeah they just move their arms so fast
jeez it's been stunned stupefied
nobody makes me bleed my own blood
oh knuckle sandwich
you could pay my entire rent now right
brings other people oh he's
fighting dirty all right
smart
oh
wow
got a point so much Style
with such an effortless Grace
golf I see hello God pay your fees
Donnie Yen is just so endearing and charismatic
when he smiles I like melt in my soul I know I
just wish anyone would smile at me
like that I just feel so comforted
can I see
what if I hired 10 men with weapons
to come here to challenge us
wrong come on he's not made for this world
if you're just too good that's always
yeah
who would read this now
oh this poor guy attention monso yeah
oh poor guy
oh no
it's wartime man how is it your fault guys
or I'll whip your ass it's wild how
important respect is in this culture sure
respect and etiquette yeah
famous last words you think he's
learned enough to win I don't know
okay maybe he has it oh
I don't know that was not a good
sign with the hat was not a good sign
whoa
nice also he was told to run so
ah oh no oh no oh geez
it's not funny but he learned enough at
least for one it's been progress now live yes
Ransom it's like a lawless land you can't do
that it's like the Wild West in a way just
instead of like you know gangs of Ruffians
you just got different factions of Masters
of kung fu the cigarettes the martial arts
bizarre you gotta have one Vice in this slave
but it's also the third you know like
smoking was good for you back then it's
actually 1950 here there's the title card
up at the top but still you know smoking
was good for you in the 50s right because
he has such great endurance yeah that's
how is probably he trains with the smoke in
his lungs to make them much more capacious
oh wow Jesus
how
many men is this way more than
10. yeah do we get a count
yes
ah
wow
nice teamwork way more usage
of props in this one yeah
and like more cutting in general but last time
we had feathers now we've got wood yeah wow
whoa don't get mad at me don't you want
to see him on Dancing With the Stars
yes now I didn't know I would but now I do that
work is so great his kicks oh sure and
he's so light on his feet yes So Graceful
no run 20 more
damn
nope oh smack him hello what's up
oh geez no oh hey what he's back let's do this
for the master oh [__] oh no oh no foreign
they're arresting him for what this guy owns the
street you know what are you gonna do it's this
word against IPS okay so this one so far still
great more out there than the first one yeah yeah
yeah welcome have a seat you have a little
something for me I feel represented finally
it deals this is my favorite character
three percent
you tell me I'm not gonna talk about
that now thank you he's in a different
movie right now a little bit as all white
folks should be our own moving foreign
well done I love that it man accepts anybody if
they come as the best version of themselves like
he doesn't need an apology just happy to have
them be good yeah you can see the growth yeah
come on
oh he's gonna send one of them he's
gonna trade himself for the kid right
can go oh yeah oh geez
oh
yeah
you're making me look like an idiot from
a master hoop he's a funny character yeah
big question
I love his growth and that I can now
actually be excited to see him yeah yeah
totally he was such a dick yeah and they
completely faked me out in the first one
idiots y'all don't even know about it
you're gonna put some respect on that name
challenge accepted he goes by everybody
else's rules too to show respect like to
the systems man it man is just Class Act
absolutely and probably to show that he
can he's not so rigid that he can't
just adapt right he needs to foreign
well don't all jump up there at
once a bunch of wimps I've seen
he keeps doing this like squint like the
whole thing an interesting active Choice oh
how does he fly like that he's got
an interesting Vibe about it yeah
really interesting I'm kind of liking his choices
wow some of these shots are nuts
hey did he punch him in the balls
they are letting me win he tries to
like save everybody's rest dignity
truly Leader by example impeccable in his word
whoa whoa
wow nice
oh geez
I was rolling off the table oh
yeah get up there boss man put your
money where your mouth is he's like
The Godfather we're like Tony Soprano or
something sure yeah whoa oh my foreign
oh man take
come on Jimmy Olsen capture the magic
that's so cool
no no no no no no oh okay
whoa whoa
the double such a clever way to raise tension
this is bloody knuckles over here
the table
that's so [__] cool sick Murphys
foreign
what's a hundred dollars a month going
to I don't trust you you're making a shop
it's like a protection fee on your
against your own people yeah it's
like what if you've got the police and stuff
in your pocket too you're probably uh just
just paying it's like paying the mob yeah
maybe a little more respect but generally
um
ah
well done my guy respect him yeah no I'm here
for it he invented pictures in the newspaper
no no don't do it don't do it no whoa bad bad bad
bad boys is about to become the raid right now
oh geez no guys oh my gosh you guys are
how old are these are they teenagers
because they're acting like children
it man's people are the ones at fault here as well
yeah and they're destroying other people's art and
work look what you're doing to each other they're
all just itching to fight man there's no winner
everyone's a loser it's like Alien versus
Predator oh I'm so upset with you guys
wow oh man I'm devastated the
further we get into the story
of it man the more I'm afraid
he's gonna snap it's supposed
snapping type no that's what I'm afraid of like
where's the breaking what is he gonna say to
them right now like get it together because
you guys just destroyed Something Beautiful
we've been here before
of course it is it says every
person with a clear conscience
oh my god dude
oh
wow
foreign
snack on some Pearls of Wisdom
it man's just the best bro he's
like one of the greatest protagonists
of all time so easy to root for him
oh
yeah
foreign
that's a bar it's striving not to
strive yeah don't try too hard just
kind of be here now and flow be like water yeah oh
all right what version are you of you are
you bringing to the table today sir yeah
did you learn anything from
the last few times we've spoken
what I say Joy
enjoy that's settled change in the tune so
he's inviting him to watch or participate
he's just inviting to watch maybe he's gonna
show them kind of what they're up against now
oh good that's good
ouch clearly you're fine enough the way you are um
will somebody get this yellow piece of fat
out of here you're making too much noise
foreign
yeah it's good they got his back at least I kind
of like him too as the perspective yeah return
now you see what he's up against the British
dude socks the fighter like someone's got to
teach that dude a lesson man someone needs to
deck that dude in the chops a racist [__]
I knew it it's like they have
very different ideals in a way
but a similar kind of Integrity it's
like the traitor from last time uh
God what a weird game to have to play now
marketing and publicity it's not pantomime
Taylor this is Chinese boxing do you know this
actor I believe the screaming gives them strength
well I mean you let out additional
energy when you oh my God oh my God
oh my God you hear him he said let's give him
something to scream about I hope they kick his
yeah all those dudes should be able
to take this guy down kill him punch
nice
whoa
more power come on I hate this I hate this
I want to fast forward jolly good jolly oh
oh what come on no you should
stick to dancing quinoa
what's this oh Jesus
oh no oh no some some real
button it's gonna happen oh no no
yeah he gonna get hurt real bad enjoy the show
and now he's probably gonna cry because he got
hit it man will destroy you [__] yeah dude
oh buddy he's not gonna be the same like it was
all that you beat up on all their students yeah
he wants you to apologize what is this some stupid
Chinese tradition the winners have to apologize to
Losers or if I had to do that I'd be apologizing
every day I hate this guy hate him he's a good
actor though he's good at this yeah and you beat
me in a fight yeah right now and I'll apologize
I was gonna say how this is gonna
go with just all punches on his
side he's Gotta Lose right because IP
man's gonna have to come and beat him
at some point and so it's not gonna
make sense yeah he's probably gonna
do some dirty he's probably gonna cheat yeah
something really dirty he's gonna get hurt
who's in master hung's
Corner IP get up yeah foreign
because he's got the whole like
political array to figure out
he's gonna find out a way to beat
this guy without beating this guy yeah
oh my God
yeah get him on the ropes all right
come on man are you okay
oh boy I'm very worried
the fact that we met these characters
this movie and we care this much
God the angles the camera movements are so
visceral too yeah Master's out of breath yeah
oh no oh no oh boy
oh boy oh boy wow that was pretty Boss No
but the music is telling us otherwise yeah
oh thank God for that thank God for the Bell saved
by the same literally Saved by the
Bell okay okay okay okay okay okay
yep it's not just his though oh yeah
I feel like you need a mouth guard or
something man yeah he should manage
to remind him of his kids family family take
their kids to ice cream oh no no no no no no
oh no this is like Creed man I was gonna say next
movie they're gonna be fighting Rocky no no ah
no it don't die in the ring man
what are you saying he's gonna die I think he
might I'm I'm very afraid right now sorry to hit
you really hard no it's all good it's all good
oh wow no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
come on
aha call the round like come on
let go of the ropes let go
he's like not letting go
ah
come on dude it's barely in the
room let go let go let go oh no
no
oh
that is a dead master
oh no go home boys
that's your new general that's the
new dude you gotta teach a lesson I
I hate him that was actually really hard to watch
yeah that made me sick to my stomach I am drained
right now what's wrong with people you know how
it Man's real person and the first one's based off
of that is this one based off of anything it's
a good question I mean some of at least a fair
amount of this feels again plausibly like it could
be decently based on history like is Master Hung a
person I wonder or maybe like some kind of cheeky
little nod to Samo hung or like a relative perhaps
oh how far we came
how are you feeling right now
bud yeah like dog trash I'm sure
you've seen what the local newspapers
are saying about us the truth you'd
better take care of this I do not want to
be in the newspaper once more for pulling
the Chinese the Chinese what accent was that
all EDR like what was that that was so weird
yeah that was all ADR I think the one guy
was like kind of German but not foreign
wow
damaged short pants this is what
happens to people who mess with me ugh
hold his hands what absolute worse stop
this is a war crime
what a Chinese boxer rather overestimated himself
and challenged our champion twister
reluctantly accepted the challenge
during the fight unfortunately the Chinese boxer
was so weak they needed Tick-Tock during this
time podcast something yeah one camera phone
changed everything tragically died oh my God
it's just like the most punchable to
protect my name and reputation I've agreed
to fight any Chinese person let's go up every
Chinese person the Chinese like to use these
and I would like to stick to
that tradition I doubt that
there is any Chinese fella that has
the guts to get in the ring with me
this guy this is crossed over into it it's
a hilarity like he's just I I hate him so
much doesn't never seen a villain as villainous as
that I don't wait to see this guy taken down a peg
him
throwing down the gauntlet but IP is gonna drive
him nuts because he needs that competitive element
IP never beat hung though right they yeah
had like a table split and then the kid was
there like he it's not like we know for sure
I mean I mean we know it dies in this one yeah
no pressure they're right they know
100 he's got the whole country on
his background against like a Thanos
Thanos level villain I mean this guy
sucks the two British white dudes in this
are just the the least likable people I've
ever heard of in my life they're so ragey and
completely disrespectful in every possible way
inspect your grit man oh no tight enough
said sedition huh
really ability
oh I don't know if I trust that guy but that's so
beautiful he went back to visit him after all he
did for him what an interesting like C storyline
with the guy with the duck yeah sorry I realized
that was a very vague chain of pronouns just there
but yes Quan is his name not suspicious of him if
deciding to look after this guy who did so much
for him back in photon it's just a really lovely
detail oh no oh no of course of course of course
of course is she gonna bring the baby to the fight
yes yeah hold him up give them that extra time
and then you do the red stripe of his
forehead with the blood of Twister
no she's a [__] Legend she is I mean they are
perfect for each other they are the perfect team
suffering silently but with all the Poise
when you want each other wins so bad uh uh but
it does feel rigged because we're playing with
boxing rules like the rounds and the
but they are allowing kicks and stuff
I'm a little yeah yeah what are the rules
here I'm surprised they didn't Outlaw that
I love too that it takes no joy in any of this
so many people hate the British people they're
just like such a common villain and so many people
have been gallivanting throughout history
colonizing yeah and oppressing stuff right
here yeah people hate Americans too so you know
we've all done deplorable things in times of War
you can do it I kind of want to see this guy
in more stuff yeah I wonder if he's like a
like you know a stunt actor like a an actual
fighter or something get to your corner please
yeah that is so weird that he went to go say hi
it's like they they're cartoonishly disrespectful
it's on
ow is that the first thing we've seen land
on it he's gotten a couple seems like whoa
it's okay he's taking him in he's
learning his style oh tireding him out
oh
oh oh close Fists
foreign cage
he's so sweet how you like that
how's that taste that was sick
twister you're not used to that honey okay oh
thank you
supposed to bring the Bell but he didn't I
guess I should brush up on my boxing rules
get back to your corners
that guy's a cheater the bell ringer is a cheater
it's interesting I wonder what his game is
come on buddy let's pound him like raw meat
eyes dude you swallow your mouth guard
whoa
whoa dude shot illegal hit it's a great
freeze with a flash bulb really quick
come on
cheater yeah you're bad sport
Brad please could you come
how can we figure out a way
to make this it man's fault
please tell the Chinese guy
no more kicks like these
no more kicks I was waiting for it
we're moving the goal post is that
clear twister is my actual nemesis
oh man wait wait wait wait one more kick you'll
be disqualified understand muscle memory careful
this has major Warrior Vibes sure you okay
none of this is okay kicking is half of
his sport you can't take the kicking away
or you're it's it's illegal it's you already
agreed on yeah one Style versus the other one
all that implies like otherwise you should
take away the other guy's gloves yeah Fair
come on buddy start wearing them down
let's go let's go destroy him this is a really
mean comic I hope he dies I wouldn't feel that bad
he brought it on himself he had every
opportunity wow make him go yeah
the move finish him
oh that nose is gonna be powder what dude
two three four five five everyone seven
eight nine ten [__] ah that is gratifying
that is cathart Dad won twice today
[__] newborn baby not as long as he
doesn't get shot like last time uh yeah
let's wait and see what happens here
step on him step all over him he
had his chance to be respectful
raise him up
fabol has told me everything your actions
embarrassed the entire Hong Kong police force
arrest him yes throw him in the gulag
wrong culture about I don't care
mm-hmm
I so you know oh
dude
out Sally good jolly good show if it didn't
mess up the shot I would stand I know
oh you got yourself okay yeah go
meet your kid you don't even know
your kid was born yeah go decide on a baby name
oh wow up on your feet and everything yeah
she's a legend she's a boss see you later
oh
walk that path of the righteous man can babies
just like be outside that quickly I guess
oh people must have managed back then yeah
it's a twister
it's his uncle oh you actually
whoa hey
foreign huh
that was cool that's fun little did he know
oh wow
it's like I I learned Taekwondo back in the day
but like no I want to try out some Wing Chun
it's like unbelievable It's gotta
take so long to master right oh yeah
I mean because not only do you I like this
I like this rock and roll credits music uh
yeah it's like not only do you have to I'm sure
Master various techniques and things like that
but it's also the repetition and building
the muscle memory and just you know kind of
aligning you know your mind with as cliche as it
sounds aligned in your mind with your body so that
you can kind of move and flow naturally from The
Zone without having to think too hard you know
is this taut here I'm sure it is I just don't I
don't know anybody who what's the method called
Wing Chun Wing Chun I don't know anybody who took
when John or learned Wing John there are a lot
of different I mean just even around here there
are like a lot a lot a lot of different martial
arts schools I'm sure there's one around it's like
yeah because you got Taekwondo which is Korean and
then yeah Taekwondo I know people have taken you
got karate you got Kung Fu uh they're definitely
there's like a lot of jujitsu and stuff like that
and there's a lot of um all things that like I
regularly hear about but there's people there are
even places that have like Jeet kundo which is
the Bruce Lee fighting style that he developed So
based off of this probably at least derived from
sure yeah probably mixing a few different schools
of thought I would imagine but yeah there's gotta
like I feel like especially for as prolific as
just the figure of it man is plus these movies
and things like that like there's there have to
be Wing Chun schools around what do you think of
the second one versus the first one I mean this
is really fun it's weird like hearing going in I
was expecting something much more Fantastical and
something uh yeah that just had more of that like
kind of Chinese Opera sort of style and it
definitely adds that but it's still why are
you expecting that you had heard that or you
just felt like yeah I'd heard vaguely that
the movies progressively you know get a bit
more heightened and I think after the first
one being so surprised by just how historical uh
the basis was for the story and and you know all
the just all the time and place elements I wasn't
expecting then coming out of that I don't know I I
guess it's maybe a near-sighted Assumption of like
well that's the historical story now we're kind of
gonna build out from Beyond that like this still
feels like it could easily be based on history but
I could also see uh I think an easier potential
for certain events to maybe have been truncated or
um you know like fabricated like I would be
very curious to know if this was an actual
fight that took place if this was an actual
you know competition because you know like
the the British presence in Hong Kong like
again this isn't history I know intimately
well but yeah like all the history lines up where
I'm like okay so we're still grounded there and I
guess in terms of colonization and like who
the villains were at the time kind of stuff
you mean yeah and just like what the tensions
are in culture both uh you know just between
the people who were trying to make it by Under
This rule all the different you know Chinese
folks who are just trying to make their livings
and then um you know how that further interacts
with you know the actual tyranny going on or at
least the actual colonization occupation and how
they are running things and how they are sort of
directly influencing this like I like that you see
um yeah it's like you meet Master Hung and
you see this sort of status quo of this new
environment that we're in and how you know the
different schools interact with each other but
then you see like the great instead of basically
having this big shift into everybody now being
sort of plopped into this nightmare situation of
the Japanese Occupation now it's like you're here
you find out one status quo only to be introduced
to the greater status quo above all that which is
you know the Brits and what they are doing and
how they are treating everybody and the greater
concerns that go beyond just you know our uh you
know it's like him and Master Hung there's so
much of like it's not just it's not as simple as
just you know fighting back in a certain way it's
like you kind of have to step carefully around
this situation and all that stuff just kind of
felt if not built ripped from this guy's actual
history at least plausibly ripped from history
so yeah yeah I'm I'm with you I I also think
that but it what was really working for me about
this is that it's about the the impression
people have on each other based on nothing
based on ignorance you know it's uh because when
we're talking about the historical aspect of it
um it's also just about how British people felt
about people that they deemed to be foreigners
and what their lack of respect of other cultures
is and watching this it's about being equals and
being respected equally in the the lesson at the
end about dignity and about integrity being it's
it's not about proving you're better than or that
this school of thought is better or that this
school of um fighting is better it's about being
respected and having different methods that both
work simultaneously and yeah I thought that that
was really cool because I was beforehand I said
to you as we were coming in this movie I was like
I'm a little nervous because how how is this gonna
be as people say this one's really good how is it
gonna be good compared to the first one which we
both loved but I thought the first one the reason
that I really loved it wasn't just because it was
a fighting movie it was because of all the other
stuff surrounding it that really elevated it and
grounded it and so in this one I was like okay so
we know it's not going to be about the Japanese
Occupation so what what can they do that makes
me feel like so much anger towards an enemy or
a villain and doesn't just make it like inner
fighting you know yeah it doesn't come with
that tragic element yeah and fighting what they
decided to do in this one I was like oh right
they just are following the the timeline of
uh of the bullies and oh yeah bullies bullies
throughout history totally totally I thought they
did a really good job of that but then at the end
not being like huh we were always better than you
it's ha we always deserve to exist yeah yeah yeah
and that universality of people's dignity above
all else and I think that's you know it's such a
cathartic resolve because like this movie does
have I think a different sort of tonal height
especially with the British characters like in the
first movie The Japanese antagonists are much more
there's just a different Mystique in a different
kind of grounding that they apply to those
characters whereas here and it is interesting
because this is you know like a Chinese production
and all that stuff and so like whenever like yeah
of course of course you're gonna look at it like
that yeah and whenever like Brits or Americans
show up in these kinds of movies and even speaking
English there's just like a different kind of
Timbre to how the performances go but I think
just in the tone generally they had much more
without it working against the movie like it's not
complaint but there was like a a greater height
a more over-the-top quality to the antagonists
here that does kind of elevate the fantasy level a
bit you know it does have like more of a clear-cut
sort of enemy situation just because twister and
his like main Handler guy uh with the British army
is they're just so pompous and so disrespectful
all the time and uh you just cannot wait to see
them have their asses handed to them and I think
they do nicely to make them formidable like
twister is for me at first I was like what are
you gonna do you're a boxer these people like no
kicks and and various like combinations of things
and not to slight boxing it is just a different
school of thought and style of fight but yeah
it's a different sport it's a different sport
with different rules and I feel like you know if
you're applying that I was surprised it took them
so long to be like hey we got to take these kicks
out of here I'm like he's not even wearing gloves
like this is you know which I get the point is
to be like we're gonna prove that our method even
with all the advantages given to you is better um
but yeah it does it does make me kind of curious
to learn more like these both make you want to
go and and you know kind of uh immerse yourself
in some kind of martial art but it also made me
curious to kind of learn better the just sort of
lexicon of boxing and how that works definitely
very true the this movie the main fighter twister
he is not the villain as much even though you hate
him it's really the other guy that bothers me so
much the British dude skinny short pants yeah
short pants dude because the thing about twister
is that Fighters today 2023 in this country a
lot of them are [__] they want to fight not
all of them but like a lot of people well there's
an element of the show of the show and the sh and
the crap talking and the you know like I'm gonna
beat you know it happens to this day where people
get injured in when you sign up to fight somebody
you know like there's some serious injuries that
take place so as much as I'm like oh my God
you're the worst you suck because you have a
judgment judgment our entire culture that's false
and you're ignorant it's like as opposed to the
last one the main villain was also the fighter you
know this one the British dudes short pants he's
not a fighter he has just like it's so annoying to
watch him because you can't even like if anybody
threw one punch at you you would be out you would
be destroyed but in the last one at least the guy
at the top was like the one who gets in the ring
at the end and you're like you have to have some
respect for that the reason this one tall short
pants dude was so annoying is because it's just
like all of us sitting at home when we watch
fights being like punch him order play faster
and it's like bro you would be out in two seconds
yeah you hide behind your status and your and your
station and you think that you're the king of the
world just because of that and you come in and you
hit somebody's hand with a stick yeah you have
no skill yeah you gotta have the second guy held
down and it's just for yeah hold them tighter
what because you because you would be screwed
if there weren't five people holding him yeah
because you have no ability and if you didn't
have your political leverage here which I thought
they made some interesting stuff out of because I
didn't know where to go they just kept calling the
character fat so I don't remember his actual name
I feel bad calling him that but like no I wasn't
sure where to lean with him and I liked that
ultimately it seemed like he was sort of he he was
true to his word he's like no print the truth and
I'm gonna go tell him that this I'm gonna go tell
you know I don't know the MPS or whoever that this
guy is severely out of line and is not you know
is you know there's that thing of of course they
have the upper hand and there is an oppression
Happening Here of some variety and there are
deals being made and all that stuff but you know
it's like the guy is asking to be you know to at
least taken down from his station and and you
know tried for all kinds of misconduct yeah and
so I wasn't expecting that but I was like oh cool
well at least you know they're gonna show up and
maybe I don't know reprimand this dude a little
better or again at least yeah remove strip him
of his ranks and all that stuff it's like you want
to see that guy get get the [__] beat out of him
but definitely yeah but it's it is still this is
him getting the ship beat out of him in his world
in his yeah you're losing your power yeah and
like without your power you legitimate change
nothing I think that uh I'm we were like joking
around for a second about if one camera phone just
a podcast whatever it is but it is crazy that
today you know we always talk about people say
like there's so much more oppression there's so
much more and it's like this is just in history
we just don't have the camera phones to show what
pieces of crap everybody was still wore yeah and
that's that I love that little Motif they bring
in of like he the um oh God what's his name the
the um the guy from the Mill's son who gets the
job of the paper and uh he's doing the pictures
the one who calls him Uncle man or yeah Uncle man
and uh yeah he's like putting pictures in and you
realize like yeah all they had to go off of like
a radio broadcast and you know the newspaper and
those things can easily you watch I think in one
in that press conference as they spin the fight
with Master Hung about being like you know uh he
reluctantly said yes yeah you know twister was
like I guess you know and you know he only threw
a couple punches and I guess this guy just he
just really overestimated his ability and twister
did everything he could to hold back and uh then
this guy died and you know Mr gets on the mic and
Twister's like oh and then you're stupid incense
and whatever and I'm like you are the worst you've
been punching ahead one too many times my dude
and like that's the thing is it's an interesting
it's an interesting quality that they get you to
a point where you are I don't know like the
philosophy of Ip is is such that you wouldn't
root for someone to really get beat up in any
situation but they're good at bringing you to
this point where you're like nah these dudes are
bad dudes and even IP realizes like I have to
teach these guys a lesson and I also have to
lead with my example you know I have to show
everybody around me that you know we cannot give
in like it kind of complements all that stuff at
the beginning because there are things about this
movie that are kind of similar structurally to the
first one you start out with just a bunch of sort
of clashes between different schools of martial
arts that also apply to again the hierarchy of
uh you know it's like hung seems like he's put
in this position to be an intermediary between
the people who are really running the show and
then he can kind of run things on a day-to-day
basis and so yeah you go from all these squabbles
that feel like they exist on that level that then
ultimately Crest into this bigger thing where it's
like you're being pulled into some competition
that the odds are stacked way against you because
it's all controlled by these Invaders and stuff
like that yeah the infighting is so stupid because
it's really it's not each other you're mad at
you're mad at the circumstances that none of you
have money none of you have the food or shelter
that you need yeah the other similarity between
this one and the first one there is a bunch but
in the first one and in this one it kind of took
me a minute to know what story we were gonna tell
like it's not like you know a typical three-act
structure which we see in a lot of Cinema where
there's then the inciting incident at 10 minutes
in and then we break for act one act two you
know it takes us kind of like until maybe 45
of minutes into these like that midpoint or or
a little before that Mark to be like oh this is
what we're doing because at first you think that
this is going to be between Master hung's students
and Ip Man students you know they kind of point
it that way and it takes a long time to get to
actually the enemy of your enemy is your friend
and if we could all just kind of we there's more
of us than there are them and when you do join
forces and merge then you're more powerful and
it and in both this movie and in the first one
it does it takes its time it really breathes at
the beginning I think that one of the reason I'm
liking this so much is that the structure is so
different than what we typically see in American
Cinema which tells you immediately this is what
this movie is about now you know this is what the
movie's about and this is kind of like wait for it
well yeah it looks like we gotta hop in you know
first five ten minutes we've got to know exactly
what's going on and like I I yeah I really like
the grad visual build and and the way that again
both movies sort of allow you the first one has a
much more harsh like nope that the occupation has
now happened and everything is about to change
the colors have changed the flags have changed
yeah locate everything yeah everything's changed
yeah whereas here it's this yeah slow build up and
you catch you know if and his family in a more
working person's position you know okay we're
in this new place we gotta start up a school we
got to find a way to make money we're struggling
a little bit okay here are this these little
you know again Petty squabbles and the little
difficulty like I love just the build of you have
it first you know this guy who comes in who's like
yeah I'll see about paying your fees uh you know
if you could defeat me and you start on just this
yeah this just little whippersnapper who becomes
his first student and then his little Crohn's
who then become the next batch of students and
then you have the schools fighting and then you
escalate into an in like an unfolding situation
it's not so much that there's like a harsh tone
shift it's not like oh snap now the bridge have
arrived it's just oh you didn't realize what this
the shape of the Fishbowl you're in is you didn't
realize how many layers there are and so I think
that creates a nice sort of gradual Dynamic to
where yeah things start out really on the ground
level and feeling very intimate and and just sort
of day by day and then you slowly Crest into this
like huge sort of problem of principle by the
end it would be obviously I know that this was
they say 1950 something but it it would be cool to
see some of the women fight a little bit I know I
was gonna say what are we are we pre-time where
that was like an acceptable thing for for women
to do I know when we in the first one obviously
when everybody's training everybody starts to
train in the uh the factory and stuff remember
whatever so they you know no people left out but
it you know I would like to see his wife pull
a couple punches and do or do a couple things
it'd be cool if some of the kids signing up when
they're teens or whatever oh dude I know people
are gonna rip on me for that I'm sorry that I
want women to be able to fight too I'm so sorry
guys well they did it in the first book I mean it
wasn't like a big focal thing but they at least
trained all the people at the Mill and some of
them were women and some of them were shown on
screen throwing down so that's what I'm saying
like you know in the third one maybe one of the
students maybe just one yeah yeah it seems like
you could like to be a woman practicing martial
arts at this point in time either things have to
be so desperate that everyone's doing it or maybe
you're just that special but but yeah like I am
maybe a little bit surprised by that and it seems
like the further we get into this just historical
timeline the more it seems like everybody should
know how to defend themselves a little bit just
because you never know who you're going to be up
against both like home and from abroad that's what
I'm saying I think it's an easy way in the third
one like to train your wife you know you want
her to be able to ask your kids when you're not
home and it'll be nice to see she could handle
it I can't imagine her fighting because she's
just so she's crazy so but then again she's got
all these qualities where I'm like that would
probably eat in your fighting ability to make
you very graceful and light on your feet oh I
feel I feel you guys are already hating on me for
it I'm sorry it's one note it's a little note I
love the movie at the time you know I'm sure that
and and two I mean I don't know and bringing that
up I'm sure that there is history as to like
when it became more prominent and acceptable
for women to join in this kind of you know study
in school of thought and uh and hey maybe there's
some of that to come who knows I really have
no idea what do you think about the third one
is there anything that you would really want to
see or is there anything that you would expect
I have so so curious do you want to go to the
Bruce Lee route like we just met little Bruce Lee
I know and and in the part I just freaking Netflix
man like I feel like you should know on movies
like this where it's like the I had to go back and
and Rewind The the little uh captions at the very
end because it said he finally took Bruce Lee they
show you like a bunch of [__] you're supposed
to watch next and I'm like there are subtitles
yeah it's so annoying uh but apparently he took
on Bruce Lee in 1956 as it says here and so we
meet him when he's like a child here so yeah we
we must be on like the cusp of the 50s here like
just just before just around and so yeah like it
man three I guess I would expect it has to be
approaching the 50s or 60s or something so I
would I would imagine a Bruce Lee presence of of
some kind I almost don't expect him to be like
a main character but maybe I mean you know that's
a fun little kid messing around starting to learn
yeah like a teenager just sort of part of The
Ensemble but maybe not and maybe even like with
a bit of spotlighting but not yeah like the main
supporting character necessarily um I don't know I
mean and then villain wise are you expecting them
again to go this route where like it you know at
first it is Japanese people then it is the Brits
she wants them to stay in that British hemisphere
that's not the right word in that angular
realm yeah thematic realm I don't know
I I do like and and this one the first movie is
much more of like this is a historical drama and
also you know very much a martial arts movie with
creative Liberties for sure sure this one is a bit
more martial arts movie certainly still historical
drama but a bit more steeped in and focused on you
know these various fights and and things like that
I feel like there's just a little bit more Scene
stuff between the fights in the first movie
which is not a complaint um I guess I would
expect in the third movie to be still pretty fight
heavy I have to imagine though that there's you
know they're always testing IPS Poise and pushing
him to a point where he has to fight in order to
inspire people and while on the one hand I'm like
well it would be cool to try a different Dynamic
I do think that is kind of a Cornerstone because
of his personality it's like he's got to get to
that point where he's like I have to do this not
for myself not for the fight not for a show but
because this is for everybody like I'm fighting on
behalf of a principle for everybody so I feel like
that kind of needs to stay intact but I'm also
like I don't know what what we could do in history
that's gonna force that to happen so yeah I have
no idea I can almost expect maybe some kind of
left turn or maybe some kind of America presence
in the next one I don't know people like the third
one people love the third one also right yeah the
only people seem very chuffed on the entire series
I've heard more mixed things about part four but
at least the first three people seem to love kind
of unanimously so either way I'm excited no matter
what but I yeah I kind of of him like each I think
it's good I think it's a sign that you you really
you know put it all out there when you get to
the end of one of these movies and you're like
or what we're gonna do next man totally aside
for maybe just like IPS still trying to run that
school yeah he left it all out on the floor some
bullshit's about to sweep in and he's gonna have
to take up the mantle and you know well maybe we
have a school for him you know they took away this
school so maybe there's a more established school
yeah maybe in the third one he's finally able
to have like a few locations it's a franchise
franchise man totally I hope that that one main
guy that first came to fight him that then became
his number one pupil stays in the third one from
this one yeah the guy who shows up at the top yeah
I do too they said there's one like throwaway line
word there like he's okay he's resilient so I'm
sure he could come back and I would like that too
like I think it would be like I like the way that
this movie in not a huge in your face way but you
they brought back gin and they brought back uh his
buddy from the factory with the duck and that
was really tragic um that was I felt really bad
for him well there's ramifications of War time
you know and I think they were showing that and
um this guy I liked and want to see him move
forward because especially that one conversation
they have when they're sitting there and he comes
to apologize to him like I took your school away
from you and I felt like that showed humility
in a way that a lot of young people don't have
and realizing yeah that under he clearly is
starting to understand the message that it's
not just about like you know proving yourself
or fighting for your own reputation here in the
moment there's much more you can't be goaded by
people and you have to rise above that and that's
principle that your Martial Arts should inhabit
and you can see him really taking that to heart
in a moment like that which I think is really
lovely because you know so many of these guys
are just itching to throw down yeah totally the
second they walk in they're like let's fight
it's like you gotta burn that my dude yeah it's
like our school's the best and you know it's I
do appreciate that that so many people show up all
cocky and then all you got to do is is like really
you know whoop them a little bit and they're like
teach me yeah on their knees I'm completely open
to your training and philosophy now yeah I'm with
you yeah I don't know like it's it's just I love
you know I have to imagine that this is somewhat
based on the real guy's personality I just love
the personality of he is such a great centerpiece
because there's so many characters in such big
situations and in a lot of ways it's not just like
that's the cool part about the historical aspect
is it does feel like a broader thing about a
lot of people but it just so happens that he
is at the core kind of anchoring the grace of it
all yeah definitely I mean I I think I said like
15 times throughout I love Ip Man like that's
it it's a good thing that I love the character
because the whole movie is really contingent on
you really liking him and he inspires like it's
an inspiring character like you you want to take
that level of poise with you wherever you go in
that level of Grace yeah I was kind of thinking
about that as we were watching too the way that
he says every time he wins the fight like thank
you for letting me win yeah I was like um I think
we could all use a little more of that you know
instead of rubbing things in people's faces or
even like congratulating yourself just immediately
trying to make somebody else feel better about
their loss yeah because because yeah it's it's
not about a fight for him even it's like it's
just a demonstration it's just the chance of this
particular fight because he knows he's the best
I guess so it's weird it's like I don't even
think he's thinking about it I don't think he's
no I don't mean it like that I just you know
when I say he knows he's the best as in like
he's got nothing left to prove to himself yeah
he's just like I I don't have to impress you
and say like I won because it we ever it is what
it is you just saw so I'm secure in my ability
I don't have to prove anything and yeah like even
if I did happen to lose it wouldn't be the end of
the world I will lose so I like that too that
whole thing about like hey in 20 years you'll
be able to beat me no one's the best forever you
know yeah he just seems like a very Zen guy yeah
yeah grounded is a good word for it you know not
too much in and also yeah like it reminded me of
that line he says in the first movie to to one of
the pupils about like you know you can't be just
all up in your head about technique you know and I
think that's another big thing that these kind of
hone you in on is like I loved when they outlawed
the kicks and he throws one out and you're like oh
yeah yeah you're probably so used in it yeah those
reflexes and it's part of what makes you so good
but now that's a that's a handicap because you've
got to factor all that out and you've got to now
be thinking harder in the moment and that's a
great little way to drive up that that tension and
yeah it's like even though there are Beats that
are similar they all feel very natural and they
don't feel like rehashed or derivative or anything
like that yeah he's Ip Man he's very quick he's
quick man whip man oh I'm gonna say you know as
much as he doesn't seem like the kind uh you know
to be a ball buster I bet he's got some quips
I bet he's got some quests every now and again
he'll sneak one by you that you're like ah like
I didn't even catch it at first but ah you got me
yeah it's like I said we can't watch him and
Master Hung like be Pals now because it seemed
like there could have been like a really fun
friendship I am bummed that he died and can't
be in the next one maybe we'll get some Throwbacks
to him but that that is it that's it was awful and
the funeral was like such a different looking
setting from everything else it's a really good
job of that minus the hood the pointy the whole
pointy hoods are historically uh unfortunately
problematic uh given what's yeah they're given
what we will soon do with them in history or
may have been already probably doing in history
with them um but it was yeah very striking to
be like oh we're in a space that is just like
all white and and and and everything is very
like peaceful or well it's that mournful Serenity
but also everything is like a little bit more
pristine than everything else you know because
you want everything to be you know as as nice as
it can be and you're in a place that is sort of
impoverished nobody has money not not everything
is like you know kept in ship-shaped cleanliness
or whatever so it is like a very there's like a
sterility that comes with the mournfulness there
um but two just huge props to Sam oh hung and I'm
not like the biggest expert I've seen a few of his
uh films of Jackie Chan most notably and maybe a
couple others that Center on him but he's just
I mean he's prolific in Martial Arts Cinema and
Chinese Opera and stuff like that and I thought
he was Opera yeah yeah which which not not uh
not the same idea as like you know a operatic
song I don't know anything about Chinese Opera
um again I'm not like a huge expert but I I have
you know did a little bit of reading in that
Jackie Chan biography and they came up together
and yeah just to see him I mean he's such a
prolific again martial artist and you know martial
arts movie presence both in front of him behind
the camera so you know you have Donnie Yen who's
already such a terrific actor and martial art and
then that's you know like a real lucky thing going
from this these movies to like John Wick chapter
four it's like Donnie and obviously he's got the
presents and the moves but he's like a great actor
too yeah he's really good and a table scene man
that was like again and yes like such like the
concept of that is so great because yeah it's like
you gotta focus on the fight but you also got to
focus on your surroundings because you're going
to be tilting and whirling and the way they shot
that too like that's another part of this movie
that seemed like it got a bit more Juiced up is uh
they cut they was there were more cuts
and there were more sort of crazy angles
and camera movements a lot of like interesting
little like zooms or whips and things and not
in in like a really good way I thought like you
know especially in American action you can see
things that are just edited to hell and it's just
like throw every camera angle at it and people
will get the idea whereas here I think it takes
it's like you have the fight choreography which
is already impressive and mind-blowing on its
own but I thought they stepped up even further
on the camera choreography to accentuate the fight
choreography um and yeah like superbly exemplified
in that uh table fight with all the little chairs
and and the subtle use of of I would imagine wires
for certain stuff you know going into that
you know slightly more Fantastical style but
but keeping it very grounded in the in the use of
those even still you're not like full-on Crouching
Tiger crying but you know there is a little bit
more of that lightness of air in there definitely
the the movie does a really good job of telling
of showing us how to feel based on everything
other than the script the script also does that
but like with the colors and with the the music
which like especially in the fight scenes you can
hear in the music oh oh something's coming you
know and like you know how to feel and it's kind
of um training your mind when you're seeing the
different colors and some things are lighter than
others and some have a little more pop to them and
um all of that it's letting you know what's coming
not in like a spoiler way but just uh this is bad
this is good this is what this looks like they
really thought about all the elements and then
we talked a little bit about the use of props but
I just felt like the props in this movie really
elevated the fights from and differentiated the
fights from the first movie because in the first
movie we had these incredible fights and then
yes in the factory with the feathers and all of
the things that went down but in this one the
the usage of that wooden board right or of all
the knives yeah there was just so many different
elements that made it like imagine being on set
rehearsing for this movie you know imagine those
fight scenes like how are you doing that like how
do you do that there's so many moving parts and
everybody's got their own thing and some of the
shots we're seeing dozens of people do the
their thing at once and you're working with
tools and props that like you really can't f up
and they're all so trained in a way that's like
I mean it's the coolest dance you've ever seen
in your life just the way that they have to do
all that as somebody who has been on sets before
I can't imagine the pressure every single person
is under and also just like how you do that
just seems like it would take a million hours
yeah and from what little I know again about how
they do it in in Chinese and Hong Kong Cinema is
is yeah it's like you have this intense level of
choreography but I think you also have on the FL
it's like here in our action movies there's lots
of Regulation and there's lots of you know making
sure that everything is like super duper safe
whereas from my understanding more kind of you
know from from my understanding in these movies
there's more sort of like let's figure it out on
the day and let's you know kind of throw stuff at
the wall and see what works and kind of there's a
maybe a little more spontaneity and also just a
little bit more acceptance that like yeah you're
gonna get hit a little bit you know we're gonna do
some of these things pretty fast and we're gonna
do some of these things in ways that maybe aren't
the most safe but it seems like everybody is game
for I think it's just a different sensibility like
on the one hand I'm like yeah like so many things
could go wrong and and here in America you're
like how many ways can you get sued but yeah I
mean throughout again watching hearing accounts
of different crazy stunts and stuff like that a
lot of of it is like kind of held together on
a shoestring and it is just about you know a
group of people kind of working it out on the day
and finding the coolest thing that they're all
willing to throw down for right the freestyle of
it all is probably why it looks so good but sure
it does sound a little dangerous to me but also
if this is your craft and that's how you want
to deal with it you are right like this with the
who's gonna get sued that mentality definitely uh
prevents art from being the best that it can be
sometimes yeah it's like I'm sure coming like
crossing over I'm sure it's probably a lot more
fuss to do an American action movie than like a
Chinese action movie for a lot of these types of
actors who are you know heavy into stunt work and
martial arts like you think Donnie Yen for John
Luke was like oh this is how it's done all right
I mean he knows well enough about it see the thing
is watching a John Wick movie part of Migos okay I
feel like these guys probably are steeped in this
kind of Cinema too and that kind of tradition so
if ever a Hollywood set was probably more willing
to be like ah you know we're kind of all stunt
people and even the like actor actors who are here
most all have gone through some level of training
so we can probably play a little more loose with
those lines but yeah I mean in general I think it
would be a bit more restrictive crossing over to
here it's like you watch something like John Wick
four and you're like I don't think Donnie Yen was
restricted in any way totally he was asked about
his character for them I think he said they were
like did you base it off of and he said I just
wanted to be as badass as humanly possible or
something yeah mission accomplished man that he
the thing about him being so charismatic is he can
blink and I'm like intrigued sure but even when he
was looking so much Presence at master um hung
and they they're looking at each other and and
um he you can tell he doesn't want Master Hung to
keep fighting because he's about to die but their
eye contact with each other was just disturbingly
upsetting you know just you're watching and it's
like desperate because what it man knows is that
he's not wrong and he's fully understanding what
this guy's real position is like I thought their
their Arc of understanding each other was really
beautifully handled and and props I started
saying earlier to Samo hung because I mean he
has just as much you know poison presence even
though he's presented as more of an antagonist
from the start like again his martial arts
abilities and his presence as a character
you know like when he goes down you really feel
for that and part of that is a circumstance but
a huge amount of that is just him and the way that
yeah I think that that that moment of realization
in him being like it's not that easy you know
like I I can't just take him down you know the
in this a I mean you know he's clearly formidable
but be there's just so much more here than either
of us really kind of can fully grasp I wonder
if his kids will be a part of the third one
you know he left behind a wife a whole family
I could totally see it what happens with them
does Master IP take care of them I can see it
and I mean they they've I think that was one
of the nice things about this is that sort of it
makes the world feel alive even though you're not
focusing on most of the characters from the
last movie in you know great depth they are
still here and they all have lived and they serve
a little purpose especially Jin showing like yeah
you can grow Beyond being this this hot head guy
so yeah like in a story like this that sort of
um you know just the sorrow and the and the
uh just the I don't know the crushing blow of
having your father taken from you in such a harsh
Manner and your husband you know take it from you
in such a harsh manner I could definitely see
those characters factoring back in I just don't
know what direction they would have to go in
yeah it might be small moments or whatever but
yeah things for more human dramatic quality rather
than like oh we gotta go on some Revenge Mission
or something like that yeah building continuing
yeah just as like a One-Stop storyline kind of
like the guy with the duck where it's like you
know we see him like three times maybe but he's
got his own arc yeah and it's just a little thing
but even that him him realizing at the end and
sort of some of that memory coming back and even
he has sort of healed a little bit through this
it's like such a beautiful little they didn't have
to do that at all you know and I thought that was
a nice again really compassionate little story
and a great way to show constantly if it's just
trying to do like the the truly good altruistic
thing for people even when nobody's watching even
you know it's not like he at this point has his
riches he gives the money for the duck even though
he can't pay his own rent yeah yeah it's just like
his use this who we should all aspire to be and
and in the most important moments is when nobody's
looking you know like that's when it's true truest
so uh not performative just doing it yeah yeah
yeah it's like he runs the Spectrum and it's like
and then when it gets to be in front of everybody
it's not even about that you know it's not for
that and it's clear and his little speech at the
end simple brief but incredibly straightforward
and super poignant yeah he says like that that's
all right that's all yeah I'm not here to talk
[__] I just hope that maybe we can all you know
be a little bit more tolerant of each other and
recognize that all people have dignity thanks
you know and and yeah I think that's really
lovely wonderful message and yeah like especially
looking at modern times there is that tradition
of [__] talking and whatnot and hey it's part
of the pageantry it's part of the fun but you
know there is a line and I think they just do
a great job here showing people who just have
absolutely no respect I mean well part of it was
just straight up racism I mean they were calling
and stuff too that's like we're so far past
the line I can't even see the line anymore yeah
yeah well golly we did it golly gee this this
certainly had nothing to say about this movie yeah
we're just such Ip Man fans now it's cool to be
part of the Ip Man Fan Club having it man one live
up to the hype it man two live up to the heights
I feel like this might be an Ip Man 3 Journey that
we're on we'll see it's coming yeah I think the
real one the real question mark for me because
sometimes also three is a nice sweet spot you know
you what are you Indiana jonesing right now that's
right because then we're gonna have to get it
man five to fix whatever went wrong in about four
and then then you're you know in a whole other
perilous game once I'm on a journey though I'm
on the journey and I'm signed up I'm signed up
I'm here for Ip Man 15 if that's what it takes
yeah and I mean even if it meant for whatever
other installment isn't you know as great as the
first I'll always be happy to check in with the
guy you know yeah totally I'll be happy to check
I'm sure there are elements that are still great
yeah well all right thank you for for enduring for
braving the challenge with me and thank you guys
as well for your enthusiasm Your Love down in the
comments we have had an absolute blast and a half
covering these and I personally would absolutely
adore the opportunity to do the next one so if
you want that comment below leave a like on the
video that helps us out immensely uh go on over
to patreon if you want to see The Full Experience
shopzeroedition.com if you want some reject swag
to support the channel that way and look good in
the process and uh hey we'll catch you on the next
one much love people be good be it man be it man